people can collect anything they want
there is zero judgment on people
choosing to just collect cool stuff that
they really love but then there are
people who want to work out now
sometimes I want to think about this in
terms of might let's be valuable one day
might this be something that is worth
keeping for actual reasons other than
you like it
and some people just make that excuse in
their head this might be worth something
one day so you know I'll just keep it
around and then of course the garage
fills up and and things get a little out
of control so hopefully our panelists
can help you kind of clear up a lot of
that thinking and really get on top of
building a collection that you can be
both proud of and potentially know it's
gonna make you some money one day if you
really pick the right things so can we
please welcome I thought I'll introduce
the three panelists and then we'll give
them all a big round applause at the
very end
please welcome stacy borg alex baz and
no no Wheatley now I thought a good kind
of intro line for this for each of you
is I think a really sort of simple
question on why do you love collecting
old games and hardware start with Alex
also being an adult is hard so nostalgia
for me it just takes me back to you know
a time when he was carefree friends
having fun and also the community I
really love the community of collectors
especially for you know any sort of
games
when you sort of hardware or accessories
magazines wherever people collect and
you always find yourself actually
talking more about it than actually
playing and that's nostalgia for me it's
number one just takes it back to a great
fun time cool
no um of course I may as well it's a lot
of nostalgia Bram this her periods have
knees in the arcades road and the
necessarily coming out in that period I
always sort of loved the games back then
and now I've been collecting about
twenty years now and I suppose in
addition to what yeah but if you guys
have said there's also a bit of a
historic theme and educational thing as
well a lot of my friends have kids now
and they've got play on the ps4 and Xbox
ones and things like that let me see if
I can roll with Ness or a I'm clicker
vision or a television something like
that and they go what the hell is that
and have you guys set for them to show
them and understand the wait game has
come from and how its progressed from
its origins for it today it's also part
of the reason I clicked as well cool I'm
also I always forget to do this I'm
famous Bernie okay I work for seen at
the big technology news website and
avoid part of the same sort of GameSpot
family so that's why I'm involved with
this but I also love all things I will
flag I still have my original color
computer too from the 1980s where I kind
of first learned some basic coding and I
remember running out of space on data
cassettes because I tried to make like
this grand opus RPG text RPG thing yeah
the next big question I think if we're
gonna try to drill into some of these
ideas about sort of value in a sense is
an Alex and I kind of throw this to you
first is you know what do you feel like
helps to make a collectible thing have
real value in a I guess you know in that
sense if I guess a lot of people maybe a
desiring it want to get their hands on
it and therefore it becomes something of
value absolutely it's some the like
production runs so for instance Atari
Jaguar any anyone that actually checks
out
eBay for instance for Atari Jaguar
software they'll find that yeah it's not
cheap so
unfortunately yeah to actually find that
sort of stuff you're gonna have to pay
for it but you know I need Tendo so
you're always very very popular so you
can probably pick those up for a good
price but anything that's a little bit
more exotic
didn't really succeed back in the day
unfortunately prices tend to go up end
condition as well I mean that's a really
interesting point isn't that actually
quite often it's things that it wasn't
the big hit of the time was it
absolutely virtual boy another example
I mean people after the techies and how
about you know any of your sort of
thoughts I know like no works over at
Bethesda as kind of a community manager
but actually while the other two guys
are kind of the Richter experts no it's
just a genuine lover of collecting stuff
so he's kind of more like the rest of us
but he takes it quite seriously apart
from the office of the rarity factor and
I being exclusive different regions of
different countries also what makes it
unique as well so if you've got
something signed by a developer who's
your own unfortunate passed away or
saying it was a prototype I'm quite fond
of got a couple of why she now only one
prototype disc for instance for men so
it's not a P an old game but still not
something you'd have really available
anywhere else I would say yes if you
love these things so you can get the
collector's editions which are
supposedly rare but not always as rare
as you'd like them to be but yeah in my
- could be saying that makes it unique
and stand out so not just a regent but
also yeah potentially something that's
been signed or something that's been
handled a bit from like so what the
Microsoft regionally sports consoles
they had the internal console signed by
the team
pure lies everybody out to the market a
couple of have that I've seen and they
own hands of collectors those things are
ultra rare I insanely rare but they're
not very common obviously comes down to
red
but yeah that sort of thing to me is
what makes it really cool they're really
rare and very very valuable um so how
about the question of like yeah I guess
I I think a big part of the rarity
issues and things like that is
restoration preservation of old things I
guess you know seeing how you talk about
these community side of it like how
important is that to the states maybe
you can kind of start this one but how
critical is that side of the love of
these things and trying to help keep
them around it it's pretty important I
think I'm the good thing about stuff
that was made back in the 80s and 90s is
it's built super well so I had Commodore
one tea light sitting in the cupboard
for 20 years you pull them out turn them
on and they're fine it's just the way
that they made those things like nano
went to the empty my opinion on consoles
we've had their fair share of problems
in you know the first a couple of years
because they amended way Manufacturing's
change in those times is big so yeah
anything all of us they're well made but
there still have the opportunity to fail
and finding spare parts is not easy but
yeah being able to keep that stuff in
good condition is really important both
but by looks and by actually working
because we want to use these things so
you know definitely I'm I'm pretty keen
on getting my hands dirty and then
fixing things like joysticks and
consoles at a broken sigh I've sort of
got a bit of a background in oh I'm
happy to do that but yes it's it's
definitely critical because yet they're
already rare a lot of the time and so
it's not to fail then you can't just
throw them out you have to really try to
keep them running
yeah definitely an important thing
there's also a cost point too I mean
normally plating retrigger games or
consoles as camp can be quite expensive
so code repeating myself he can actually
just say a bit of cash like last year's
a megaphone grand final that was
actually using one of my super nintendo
announced it can't end oh I found on a
friar pile front somebody's house I've
got a home pulling apart cleaned it up
fix it so a couple of little salt and
like a couple of breaks inside and it's
gone from literally going to the tip to
now being on stage last year but they
make it fun
fine which I bought you know it's a bit
of a pad mouth mail better be honest
yeah i've oniy of you guys worked with
Danny I know like obviously this stuff
is even becoming more important to like
museum collections and things that
they're realizing you know this is an
important part of sort of cultural
history as well so now have you guys had
or been involved with any of those sorts
of programs with emulate people can come
and actually have a go on the actual
room machines and real games and see how
they played and I love see people pick
up a joystick I'd say blew my mind
actually to pop down there the other day
and see be like endless-runner Canabalt
that has been ported back to Commodore
64 it's down there running and I double
check looking it up picking and someone
like done something dodgy here and like
put some inside these Commodores you
import it I can look like it's like no
no it's legit yeah so it's still amazing
to see that people even will go back and
code for some of these stones well
there's definitely there's a lot of
there's a lot of activity still going on
like they're in you know new games
coming out or remasters of old games so
that's still an active scene especially
in Europe I guess but actually um last
weekend I was up in Brisbane I met a
gentleman who's still writing games for
c64 putting him onto the old five and
Corinne chuckle sorry I'm here in court
I forgot my words what it is and photos
actually amazing that you know 2016 a
guys writing games for a Commodore 64
I thought those outstanding actually
it's funny because they do actually
release games on card
discs and cassette and for some bizarre
reason always got for Lucas it's making
it died if it's not a focus you can
actually load the mothers anymore
that isn't that bad look at like rather
than just the hardware itself thinking
about that kind of wider market of
accessories and books that I remember
having one of those you know how to be
pac-man type books from the 80s oh no I
know it's disappeared along gone but you
know those kinds of things in like
magazines and then there's sort of
tweeze of different times I mean where
does all of that sort of stuff fit in
with with that larger idea of you know
of this sort of retro collecting and
stuff and that's like valuers regards
what you're collecting in general um I
guess here on the value side as well
yeah and we'll start gonna really dig
into some sort of value question shortly
but you know maybe are any of those
categories that particularly ones that
stand out or you know are there any of
those things where it's like well it
doesn't really ever become something or
is it again just all about if you know
the right thing is it's going to be
worth something
a lot of the magazines and got pretty
rare everything yeah I especially the UK
ones from the aliases before the CMV
your comic or your computer your
Commodore and make a format yeah so
people throw those out you know you can
get them on PDF but there's nothing like
having a virtual magazine hands and
actually doggies and looking at the ads
anyway in terms of value and condition
that's women there are some a gazillion
can be in it
absolutely and back and back then you
would actually you'd get a coupon and
sent through and I'm gonna Activision
head patches yeah so you would actually
get a patch yeah of course
yeah and the Atari Lynx in there for
some reason in France there was a lot of
pins made for Amstrad and so if you have
a look you're actually starting to rise
up in value
it's the pins actually could be looking
at a race near the pins and patches and
they just in be more expensive and I was
never into those C's Berg huh my god
it's just more time
and I'll blame this guy on the magazines
there's also a small stocky like master
key milestone issues - like you know
issue 150 hundred stop odd that like the
comics like it exactly like it also the
US versions like Nintendo Power are
stuff like that as well you say that
it's like could be like a dollar pace
they get that sort of mass transition
and it's like yeah twenty bucks baby box
other thing it's like wow they might be
getting a half the puzzle with many many
things but now he is kind of where we I
want to stop digging to you know some of
your secrets will share with the room
and therefore make it harder for you to
track things down in future but you know
weird where do you go hunting for hidden
gems or I guess maybe it's the two sides
where's the really easy starting place
for people who maybe are just starting
to kind of think about whe where you go
and then where is some of those here
clever places that you then go digging o
to the obvious one down here stay
obviously that he's when it's eBay but
that's also pretty the evilest one is
wrong because you can find occasion what
Don's in the rough that have been either
miss listed or people aren't you know I
trying to flog them for an astronomical
price so you can't give you a rare gem
on there occasionally now for a good
price otherwise for myself personally
it's a matter of going into the markets
and garage sales and things like that
but the problem is you get a lot of
resellers know people have been out
doing the same thing so unless you're up
literally at the crack of dawn at the
end of the markets or trying the garage
sell routes around your ground where you
live it becomes quite hard the one
that'll regim that I've got that I will
shared because actually who's from
Sydney damn it it's like yawns I pop
shops and things like that and you
occasionally like dig through it's funny
like Cosette bins like you'll see people
have cassettes in there that we like
just romantic fur in there I found like
a bunch of common rule 64 cassettes in
there and now Amstrad CPC getting those
as well
even old CDs I find like the occasional
random we gain discs just stuff on a
shelf for like your classic you know
lovely great 80s and 70s rock / nineties
hits
any funny life and I am Sega CD and I
found that she was Owen that was um red
rash Sega CD and copy though I now found
recently a 3do disc from Navy speed
that's correct really sorry that's right
okay next
Gumtree is an obvious one
especially the freebies you surprised I
would actually give away stuff on
gumtree so just make sure you do your
local area I'm putting about 25k yeah
radius and pick up all sorts of stuff
markets as well
mule markets in Geelong think all Newton
is a great one that because we've
actually been there some prices are a
little bit high but if you actually have
a look they do have some reasonably good
good things there ice comics in the city
on point straight upstairs I've actually
got retry stuff up there op shops hard
waste collections guys so when you're
driving I'm in yep please take care when
you're driving but when you see a place
to pull over and have a good look and
hopefully if he hasn't mind to pick
something up be careful - anything's on
yeah yeah look I like she found a
Dreamcast kiosk oh wow on the side of
the road bikes and I actually did a
double-take I was driving down and I was
on a road in many ponds and there was
just sitting there and I thought drive
around came back and I have my daddy my
car and yeah we've said to you know call
across three lanes and put in the back
of the golf my dad having it down
driving - Kies enamel - are there any
police
I would be to say and you'll end it and
that's the last time I saw my yeah that
was that was probably cool so you ever
found so there is always stuff that so
maybe just look at you know on the
council the sights see when they're hard
waste collection zone and go around have
a look what other ones okay baby bass
evil well but I actually probably get 95
percent of my things off eBay but that's
because I'm on it constantly and I've
got alarms are loads of them so if you
don't checking once a week
you're not going to funny thing if
you're checking three or four times a
day from that you don't fall all over
the world your different points on them
so it's also a really good place to do
research absolutely
it's got great song so I can do a
completed so we stink ii actually will
look what these go for and you'll see a
variety of prices i'm not not and um
look if you've got a price you mind just
stick with it don't something will
always come up unfortunate except for
the Terrigen you can you like dig into
that a little bit more about how you use
those search tools really effective
leaks
i think some people do so the pink well
yeah I'll go and have a yeah do a quick
search and looking at okay there's an
idea but that you can kind of really set
up that whole alert system really
effectively yeah you can't actually so
um yeah I just
I'm always cost to be on my arm I find
just checking things so you know at work
if I'm going on a break
coffee break object coming a bathroom my
chicken so I'll be out of a job on
Monday so now I do theory where to you
know it's it's it's actually quite quite
cool to see when you actually do
worldwide search they see the actual
price variation across from Europe us
and obviously Australia and it's usually
the shipping that kills it's always
considered shipping
absolutely absolutely and with the fall
with the fall about dollar it's not as
lucrative as it used to be
look Japan I'm sorry the last one I've
got the last bees um the Yahoo Japan
auctions that you can't buy direct from
here but you can't get a proxy yeah and
you'll be able to pick up some really
great items and the Japanese are why
they at least they're honest they say oh
it's it's greater there's a sea but it's
absolutely premium conditions online
various options shops and things but
you'd be pleased they things take time
I haven't got much time so if I had the
time to run around all the garage sales
and everything I'll be pretty happy why
don't one other thing I guess is markets
and sin fairs sometimes they've got
things to say I'll say you know I was
lucky women's would look at Easter Fair
and the sticks and yeah I found a couple
of sort of Tommy handheld yeah and just
some bucks and everything Sam okay yeah
so just keep your eyes open everywhere
wherever there's things for sale they
could be great for games to sale so you
just got to keep your eyes open and do
your research and know what you want I
don't do that so I just can't whatever
this is whatever is available but if you
have a good idea of what you want you're
probably better off so I'm guessing you
guys might have this ball but also your
friends are great source or things like
that but they're out somewhere and I
will get messages on weekends and even
during the week occasionally from
friends here asks would you like to send
me if I don't look like it's a repro
console now I'm fine with that thank you
very casually I've seen people who send
me a bashyam the water pretty much hit
me if I have a box with a PlayStation 2
in are what's okay this is the ps2
opened up and there's like 20 games
inside the box and 120 bucks for a win
yes please thank you ah it was two more
like she just thought of ossie arcade as
well
and also Facebook groups as well quite
amazing groups that people get the
photos up there and just negotiate for
me so if you don't want to heat up a
feedback if you want to stick to
yeah that's boo an ex my wife works in
the antiques industry which is part of
where my sort of yet interest in having
this sort of panel came from was she's
always watching a lot of in facebook
groups has become a really big thing but
now ninya and she sort of good is this
thing interesting he actually showed me
kind of take thing and quite often it's
just somebody getting rid of their old
Skylanders going maybe they'll become
with something so yeah maybe let's see
how to think about some of the newer
things you know what based on all your
knowledge about collecting older stuff
you know now when people are just buying
really cool newer things what are some
of the things you feel like a hallmarks
that will help to have something become
actually you know worth something in the
future than this Classic Mini which is
already sold out so I guarantee they'll
be on eBay going up probably four times
across it there that they would have
been anything game so sorry so that
one's a classic it's the way that you
filled up one of those by the way he's
already stay out something to paint
anything from antenna it's got shell
there are Pokemon on it they do quite
well too so I have got a failure zone
for the plastic things that they come in
before you monster
I reckon it's pretty hard like year we
can all say that this is going to be
expensive but who knows if we really
knew we'd be swimming around in Scrooge
McDuck style money business oh we don't
really know but we I think it's like a
good example right now that's you know
that came up recently you know so that
there was the whole length of Disney
infinity he said a games line and then
they kind of pulled the plug recently
and now there's sort of lots of these
figures sitting unloved on store shelves
but they're kind of cool I know some
people have yeah they've loved to build
out those collections and she's kind of
Skylanders before everyone sort of
tipping them at the moment it seems
because they're deciding they've had
enough of it but then yeah did those
sorts of things even have that potential
where because something actually on that
Disney side got abandoned there's a
product line of people in how well no
point keeping these that they do then
get that rarity because people through
them all the way wouldn't be surprised
if in ten years or something they come
back and it all depends it's just it's a
market like any other it's getting
rarity and quality they things all come
in to end you need the people to want to
buy them until that happened till those
fight these come together and the fourth
one is Tom I suppose doing that because
like you could say it's like exclusive
now but you know wait twenty years and
I'd be like yeah every other person in a
box versions been torn by their child or
damaged whatever that you've got that
one pristine mass-produced Garland speak
he just uses cards example that yeah now
nobody wanted but in the future someone
who's crazed full of scars made some
sort of resurgence would want in pay you
know top of the bucks for something like
that yeah just storing all these things
as a challenger yeah point they even had
like the colored bases and stuff so you
can know what was a series one what was
a series of you all that sort of
business yeah I'm hoping this is an
obvious question but maybe it isn't if
something says collector's edition on
the box does that mean it will ever be
worth anything
maybe absolutely not it's worth more mic
to the retailer
but look Oricon a limited edition ones
definitely anything it's got collectors
on it it might be defective things are
made you know in the hundreds of deaths
yeah that's right so here what is
amazing story of them all I guarantee
that got them in every single store in a
river around Australia so I collected a
quick decision that's actually numbered
individually that that note will have
the papaya be very so yeah do those
sorts of things have that almost that
yeah there's like the trough of where
it's like yep
well no one really get on then it comes
back again at some later stage I mean
this wagon is on me I'm actually curious
you know are there any of those things
old school things from you know 80s or
90s or anything where you know people
now consider the valuable that did have
you know those sorts of tags on them
back in the day that yeah has actually
lived up to that what it said on the box
I'm just trying to each other right
there must be yeah they're they're
definitely around yeah but the fact that
it's got that ring on it doesn't mean it
doesn't mean anything
that's not that's not the cage yeah if
they had didn't have that written on it
and that was still rare and desired then
that still hold the value so yeah on its
own it doesn't mean anything so don't be
that be fooled by that if you want it
for what it is and what it comes with
because usually like I'm gonna call yeah
I'd buy them because I like the statues
and things like that but I'm not gonna
pay a premium usually just just for that
I have to just in that row time I think
I think we're we're collectors we're not
actually sellers yeah yeah and I
hopefully we're not gone it will be in a
museum or will be possible to someone to
actually almost 64 come on the other
thing I think that can come up is
shrink-wrap you know and also is there a
way to know if its original shrink-wrap
or whether it's like not you know I
think that can
times be one of those weird little games
that can happen some companies actually
do burn their shrink-wrapping like
PlayStation be example actually had
little PlayStation logo should place it
written around the shrink-wrap
I've got a home to UK versions of
manhunt still shrink-wrapped I picked up
at a garage sale for ten bucks each one
I'm really happy about Goss debating
with our opening winner or not and if
Emily - I can coffee kynapse was like
sweet so keep them there there's a nice
little hidden PlayStation thing it's
also some - you can tell because of the
materials well like some of the material
you'll see on it has she has little bits
I can say obviously tell by age and
things like that this beam of this is
like yeah you guys 30 euro game has we
have Christine Brandi shrink-wrapping
the odds of it being original is quite
here zero to none but that's what I
found for a few other things off of
Peppa Pig done if it seems too good to
be true it probably is
then do your race heads because they're
all different you can find out rules
right so yeah I know with the Jaguar
stuff I think there's some holograms as
well so I I do remember that great story
recently and I'm kind of wondering if
you guys have sort of had these
experiences yourselves or know people
who have where it was about one of the
old like original Nintendo like dance
mat track-and-field game or something
I'm not remember the exact name but
there one sold for a lot of money
because someone had you dug it out but
then another one sold there was new in
its wrapping because they saw the news
about the other one that popped up you
know they're kind of quite often those
moments where a few of something will
appear because people suddenly realize
oh that thing that's in my cupboard is
actually worth something absolutely yeah
for I'm gonna wait for Sal to actually
pull in another new I mean Tendo
Playstations but it's funny to let you
see things they're like what the trains
like that will start they'll see one
person like either a news anchor grab
that certain game or a certain year or
something like that and it's like oh
I've got one of those that must be
available now and then one
like wind Pokemon go yeah cuz mental and
I people still playing I will confess
I'm still playing it - don't judge but
when that came out I saw articles on
various websites saying how much value
how much value was now in the original
card sets and things like that cars are
going for $1,000 and said you know if
you're gonna sell himself now and
suddenly all these Pokemon cards or
Pokemon games and if you let the Pokemon
it's just going up my ex potentially I
fighting the Marten going up
exponentially in value see like people
is listing in everywhere I said I saw
the Pokemon Gameboy something led yellow
the other ones I saw those sitting on
the eBay for ages it's like you know 50
something dollars the second Pokemon go
took off I had that impact on it 150 200
199 boys listen we're going there is no
way nah but yeah it does have the impact
on four of them unfortunately
unfortunately not sure it's human nature
there and don't get mad I'll say people
getting really ticked off when you
skyrocket then just don't worry about it
something that I really really want
things but you know they score up your
bra size think good you know what just
move on yeah quickly because everybody
I'm the the long game now we kind of
touched from this a little bit earlier
but I'm wondering and also just flag
we'll do some questions shortly so we'll
do them based on the the two microphones
set up the front so in about sort of
robably five minutes i'll open it up to
anybody who has questions so keep that
in mind and the traditional situation is
that everybody's quite shy when we first
open up the questions and then there's
about eight people in the south and yeah
so don't be one of those people be one
of the first people anyway yeah we
touched on kind of values changing
worldwide and yeah I'm kind of curious
what is it about sort of that that you
know that works is it that the kind of
internal markets inside a country are
actually kind of the most important
element of value or like you know are
there certain things here in Australia
that people really kind of love and
chase and then in other countries they
can't xi chase different types of things
or easily just wait I guess where you'll
find certain things
absolutely um Nintendo was huge in the
US so I need to know way suppose for
high price in the u.s. Seager does not
all right so a Master System didn't take
off at all in the u.s. so you can
definitely pick up some cheap games from
mum you're probably why you probably
want to get the emptiest so you want
anyway but in Australia what I found is
the Atari Lynx is actually a very very
reasonable price so there's a tip
collect for the Atari Lynx and because
they're very expensive near us some very
expensive in Europe so and they're
actually really took pay for the
shipping from here but it still ends up
being cheaper for them from here on I
just hope these released they worked off
the area yeah for some reason I've been
keeping an eye specifically on that
particular system and it's just fine
that I always see it coming up on eBay
or Gumtree and they always go for a very
reasonable price so the original or the
eternal needs to either one that you
suck them into that Scott it's been at
least two three years where the price is
just been really really flat and the
games are evolved we can pick up guys
from 10 bucks I went to the Kirara
markets up in Queensland and I saw a
swag of a ton of the exclaims for $10
which so I thought well that's a pretty
good price because when I'm the US I got
40 and that's us for you I mean the
others so any thoughts on that Connie
international side of things I suppose
it's a region exclusive console like
things like the Amman is called the
cassia loopy which is a concept as a
console because in Japan designed purely
for beautiful ladies
but for Yoko for girls okay ladies big
pins yeah seems all the Japanese
exclusive I've got I've mentioned get
one racing over here because I found one
insanely cheap got it actually had a
little printing on the front a pair
these stickers because you know
apparently you know that's what girls
enjoy playing and things like that
having I'm not saying that just by the
way I'm just saying that's what the
thought process was apparently but it's
one of those things where I got it quite
cheaply and I sure the collector friend
of mine who probably tripled what I paid
for it because he'd been after one and
he'd missed a listing about it
so I got it all up with shipping 50
I was really happy about that in the box
and everything and it was just yeah it's
not one I'd seen before
and I had to sort of do a bit of
research when I seen us or what what's
this and going for and trying to find
what it was and his job ends like market
that's actually quite a unique consult
we never had in Australia so I got that
actually please get the point you're
saying before hours to about doing your
research you might see something
completely random like an apple pippin
and he just won't have a peeping out in
the wall you might not see what you
might have reckons but it was but this
super hard to get ahold of
so yeah in that one will a Australian
look at where strain release will they
when sonic she says all families for you
know like you said the Ruby yeah the
Bucks v we shall always ask is how long
I mean you might have been lucky and I
found a straight away but I don't think
people actually tell me that I say well
how long we actually keep putting one
out two three four years exactly what I
start this is that you gotta be patient
you gotta just keep on looking be JBL I
may have been looking for three years I
found it in three hours
just one of these weird little pro tip
things about searching I'm curious if
you guys use it I know that it comes up
a bit in you know sort of other antiques
industries and things like it still
works for seeker occasion as well but
eBay page me
now again you I know you've kind of said
you're most collectors not sellers but
yeah I guess if someone feels like
they've got something that they're
curious about you know hey I'm maybe I
should sell this you know how would
somebody get try to get that sense of
what what is the market willing to pay
for this thing the eBay is there but
Saul you're completing these things
because no matter what it is
why even selfies grain then marketing
putting a spreadsheet
I think anybody Kickstarter for a few
months she can actually track it people
do think that they can buy something for
five bucks
it says mm probably see that particular
least income up it doesn't sell it does
not suffer because no market for that
much so I completed solve listings
unfortunately ratios will always check
the eBay listing for the listed price
and the highest possible mr. price and
they will put that you know tender love
mario kart this cart yeah it's super
rare two thousand dollars
no thank you thank you for if you ask
extra dollar forums on what actually I
believe you done sorry
do your definitely I should be okay I
remember once a baby we'd having one of
their sales and I'd I was telling these
Dragon Age Inquisition click those
things and so I clicked on ebay just to
see what you know what they value about
ninety dollars I think they were selling
informant and on in America they were
buying just the terror cards out of that
sip like $250 but you know I but the
boys virtually sold as just the Terra
Cotta 2015 USA
wow I was like okay good so that's
wasn't really rare every seller thing
because it was a new item say but they
must have not had that yeah I mean yeah
that's a good point of even on some of
those new things again just the way that
those sets can be distributed on that
global level because there was no way oh
it's in the whole thing like if a person
I was going to get a bit yeah but just
just the pack of cards
I always file even in country town in
New South Wales and yeah going to the
local eb if there is some launch of
something where I know that up in the
city it's like all my friends I like I
couldn't get my pre-order and so oh look
I think we'll we'll get ready to take
questions down in a moment I thought
I'll just run through these guys some
pictures I've got them to kind of tell
me what some of their personal you know
like a white whale collectibles are
those like there's four things there
being a one-day track down again and get
their hands on so I think we've got a
couple things here I think Alex I think
a couple of these first ones are yours
Jonah just give us a few thoughts on
this I really love TVs white whales are
all TVs in consoles so this one's the
sharp in his TV actually coming to 40
and 21 inch it's only available in Japan
I think I'm released also in America
they also come in red so it makes squid
killers on the app control of them and
yeah yeah they are so I I guarantee
someone could probably sell those
controls for god I say much but
unfortunately they aren't cheap
predominately in Japan so she probably
got that much arrived or broken yeah
that yeah and so that's still where the
shopping is is not of yeah yeah and then
we've got the sf1 or the Super Famicom
so yeah that's the twenty I think was 21
inch so up to tiny that's that's too
sharp for your side yeah you can just
put in your Super Famicom card up the
top there yeah apply a place of games in
the Super Famicom games are actually
cheaper than a Super Nintendo pal game
so there's my tip yeah well and then I
guess yeah you're right if you've got
the TV setup you'd have to work at least
yeah it may actually do go for about
1500 bucks
that's another one with the as you can
see the control ports at the front there
and sticking out from the top and last
but not least very very expensive
divers 2006 one Dreamcast
roughly between four and eight thousand
dollars so if you give follow for four
grand and you've got a you know
something burning or cash bidding your
gun in the pocket just yeah no no no I
died is
I think I think us in Japan I love that
sweep at the back there is nothing this
is space-age more than exercycle
wasn't designed of a sonic sonic s no
it's my super air it's a tech 64's
that's a fully portable Commodore 64
systems got the tiny tiny screen there
we go I feel tonight sort of start the
keyboard doubles as it sort of leap to
the top but yeah the raid like I'm sure
we borrowed one of those back in the
back in the day so I had a friend enjoy
what brothers friend had won and so we
had a in our house for I want us like
you know it's just just love it's just
it's just an amazing system so is that
actually like a c64 but it's it's
probably wise about 20 kilos portable
but oh come on I want to ID which is
also portable to carry if you have a
computer system and a white working but
yeah it's a pretty cool and yes I'm a
bit of a pinball head so if I'm looking
to get a pinball and this is my favorite
the scared stiff the Elvira my favorites
from back in the day so not they're
around but they're pretty rare so one
day I'll find them and you say I think
when you first mention this one you're
saying that like condition is it kind of
a big yeah definitely cuz uh yeah look
if you a lot of pin balls
yeah if they don't work they're not
great but they're definitely repairable
some of the plastics and stuff are hard
hard to to reproduce like the snake yeah
but these days with Freddy printing and
stuff that's getting a bit easier to do
that so yeah really good just amazing
system so this was no this was mine
this is actually the very first computer
I ever had as a child Tandy B's at 300
I'd love this thing it was the most
amazing thing to me was a kid I've been
trying to fall in for a couple of years
now if anyone has one in a cupboard
please let me know come find me after
the show
all right your prize money so I'm
sorting once get one skate ones get rid
of a dog if someone willing to sell yeah
I think reasonable price
you know I love this thing it was the
first piece he ever get to play with
really ins the first real adventure into
home gaming of hims that point was all
arcade to me that's what got a real -
it's not worth tons but it's hard to
find
however i had to find working and yeah
it's got a real sort of you know
nostalgia hit for me it's one chase one
of those this thing this thing has been
my white whale for quite some time now
there's still battalion controllers here
for the xbox I have come across a couple
of these a few times I know some people
in the room I'm wearing at them I have
one released I just like I played the
game I played the game once actually
kinda where it was I was like a demo day
or something like that but I headed up
in Sydney I played it in sleep fell in
love because just love doing the old
mech warrior things had at times know
that the full capsule stuff is hidden
and do the full controls this to me was
like one of the most phenomenal control
systems I've always wanted one but it's
always eluded me every time I've seen
them they've been listed for an insane
price so I'm hoping against hope one day
I finally at a reasonable price or maybe
when I go overseas I'll find one that's
yeah the only reason we're getting
somehow fit into a suitcase shipping
container I'll sleep everything else arm
behind this bring that one thing back
but yeah that's definitely what am i
pretty biggest white whales I'd love
doing my hands one to be honest cool so
look I think we'll take take some
questions now if people want to
desperately rush up quickly to
Google that's gotta be here on the left
no I'm sure it'll come up visit it the
stream so yeah we could okay so with
your old systems like I've got a
Commodore 64 what do you do for
controllers because I've got a bunch of
janky controllers that don't work for
damn and I've got one in the sealed box
that's never been opened or used which
like a place I think like man I should
just use that new controller but I can't
bring myself to open the box so so what
do you do for controllers I just buy
tons of controllers I probably got 100
controllers but the good thing about
Commodore controls is it pretty simple
they're not they're not complex
electronics in there it's just buttons
and switches so you can't I've tuned
them out if you know tell me that
doesn't solver and you can you can fix
them pretty well so you can get
replacement switches but most the time
it's disconnection so like the cable and
and the and the internal internal
solving so it's they're pretty
relatively easy to fix
it's not the original Commodore one it's
it's it was marketed as a pro stick you
know competition Brown what you're
saying definitely worth repairing there
they're an excellent state all right
I'll just never throw it your controls
because they great for spare party
people do everything as well so do you
actually ever sell anything Gordon I can
we talk about value I've never sold
anything I've never actually technically
solely people my question but I have
trade or doubles and triples to other
collectors as well so they've had
something that I've wanted I was saying
they wanted servlets on that sort of
barter system it's hard to sort of part
with some of the things we spend so much
time trying to track him down or gave me
a collection that he don't really want
to part with but you vote for another
collector or somebody really wants it or
really sort of came for it but I've
never personally sold I think I like
this by night you're a hole it is as
well like a lot of the time I just want
to get stuff and get more stuff and then
some more stuff so but it does you know
if the bit if the deal comes up that you
can't resist
and evil cells how much storage space
you guys actually have not enough I put
out put it we put we like built of
Raving that roof breaks the stories I
built a room in my garage to sort of
keep my stuff being NASA it's always at
a frame then especially developing in
Sydney I guess I just sealed dust free
really exactly yeah that's you know
there were mice in the old [ __ ] so I'm
like you're not getting in here buddy
I'm like a bit a very understanding wife
I've got full rent myself and now my I
caught my my home office as well is now
like four walls full of shelter stacking
literally like over the vault run
figuring which sits I've been each from
the roof up everywhere yeah these are
all presentations you might keep the
boxes like there's always one physical
right yeah right I mean it's great to
you know if you meet like a developer
game you can't take up and say hey so
I'm a hard drive like hey this are my
original copy of your game please well
as well as the fact these virtual things
might not always work forever exactly
yeah it's not the original hardware and
the original software from Beckett and
Windows cartridges they'll just work
forever
well as long as the hardware and
software
my comment got my Super Nintendo on the
travel links is for is it when they put
some Papas on the trams and over here
okay so have a simple question what is
the most valuable things in your
collection for me will be the Pioneer
laser active which was released in Japan
and they only sold a couple thousand of
those and what you do is you actually
say replace or laserdisc movies but on
top of that it actually comes with PC
engine and genesis/mega drive packs that
you can actually interchange so you guys
should play the cards CDs and also LD
some mega LD games that's something that
people probably didn't I bet so you can
actually play sega mega held their games
on it yeah so that's why we the most
expensive item in my collection did you
get it at a good price
oh I've got a phenomenally good price
because it was miss listed not sure but
free for me there's a couple of things
like they're not valuable because of
what they are or one thing is I've got
people is one of kinds only one of ten
in the world he'll win statute it's like
life-size helping statues from the game
Killzone one on PlayStation giving you
our PlayStation Australia which actually
adored and loved his name's Roy by the
way you got named my wife I've got a
Star Wars 360 console son by Carrie
Fisher which is kind of cool and I think
the pretty the rarest thing but it's not
technically the most valuable is a
original Deus signed by Miyamoto
that was given to me and I was insanely
insanely happy when he gave it to me so
yeah
it is locked away in a safe yes it's not
it's not just sitting at the shelf on
I'm using the training every day study
I've turned it on it still works I've
gone that's awesome you go away now I
think I even have anything I don't even
know what the most valuable thing in my
question is that I keep good records
sighs I've no idea what the most
sellable key message is their favorite I
love my Commodores that's my favorite
line or my original come under one
tealights month my days of just right I
got bored I put one of the original ones
17:01 screens for like 10 bucks that was
that that's pretty much that's pretty
cool clay yes I I haven't I haven't got
many high-end items it's just not mine I
just haven't got there the means for
that sense but yeah I love all my stuff
so it's all great think of that can you
give me cool yeah I missed the first 20
minutes so I don't know if you've
covered this but um just I've got two
questions and one of them sort of you
mentioned eBay in gum trees that kind of
the main source that that's cuz I um and
I run to ebay and and gum tree but I'm
in this big forums and there's been
sites that have kind of come up and
they've just kind of just disappeared
because nobody's main place you go yeah
eBay definitely yeah totally I'm like
constantly so yeah if you're only going
to search once a week you definitely
won't find that particular item so I was
saying I actually searched I want more
coffee break long in a bathroom you know
in the morning just before I get up out
of bed constantly and I've got actual
alerts on as well so I do not miss a
thing yeah sorry the second one was um
we mentioned virtual consoles just
before I mean I I'm a collector or not
collecting for my my kids I've just had
a couple of kids in there obviously it's
gonna go pass them to them they're gonna
play awesome games I realized it's come
through my virtual world as well so must
in collections like ridiculous but
passing that on today
difficult and I wondered if he if this
actually goes into your virtual world as
well for you guys you know you stink
election in you your Virtual Console
games and classify them as collections
of all the edges the throw away well
they take collections being easy now not
lectures for anything else I guess like
yeah they're definitely a collection of
stuff and then there are things that you
can use things you can play but I mean
you look the physical collections of the
things that you can pass on and you're
at the mercy of a services more for
service hours they yeah that's come up
quite a bit in you know in our tech
coverage a lot of these services where
something disappears and it's like you
you only ever end a license you never
owned an actual feeling basically yeah
yeah absolutely
cool thank you so my question is a sort
of in regards to you mentioned you guys
have a lot of storage in regards to you
know keeping all this content how do you
actually store them like consoles and
cartridges and that's I've got a lot of
necess Ness those types of games and
cartridges how do you actually store
them in your storage plastic tubs my
winter reject shop plastic tubs Larry
yeah they're very very Hardy stacks you
sit at the top of the actual talk that
these things were built to last
I'm dead against blowing let's just be
damned it works
so I mean don't get under the house
plastic tubs way moisture that's the
main the main
moisture insects animals small children
angry the cause damage to them but I've
got my stuff see up on display she'll
surrender house from quite fortunate
about but the second we have kids those
shelves are gonna get sort of watertight
what is higher yeah yeah
with those tubs you looking for the ones
that we'd like have a really good seal
on them might as ones they just flop
around a bit of work it's my it's my bad
environment and what's you expecting
flooding you're okay but I mean you're
looking to keep out general moisture and
animals are you if you're putting him in
a place where you can get pests and
definitely important okay Manuel's
destroyed unfortunately by various
insects and pens which is just painful
they don't have specimens like here they
are now my older color competed to just
sits around in its original box and I
have to say though that it's not like
it's not in styrofoam or any being in
Hania it has got a lot of yellow or over
to you yeah alright I was just wondering
how you guys balance getting a good deal
and morals because if somebody is you
know putting something up for their
ridiculously cheap price because they
have no idea how much it's worth
is it okay to take advantage of that
human nature is that you would but I
think someone asked the question earlier
where you know we tend to sort of barter
with other competitors so that way we're
not going to you know we do know that
something's worth X amount but if
someone does not know that it's actually
better to be honest about it yeah look
if you say something on eBay and it's
actually that cheaper me going around to
you know up to genera ins houses and
trying to still take a clear exam but
then you've paid people otherwise have
plenty of means to research this stuff
so if they really wanted to do it they
could they could they can do that open
they'll just be yeah you don't want to
take a separate band if they believe it
and I feel bad if you find if you do
find something genuine that's you know
for five bucks and then it ends up being
a hundred if someone's willing to pay
for it by all means I don't people have
got an issue with that but if people are
willing to pay for it
but the other that happens to you I
think I think might be shoot people put
it up for like $100 when it's worth five
people get it for five dollars please
like 100 feet up that's that's what
they've chosen to do but my thing is I I
won't take advantage of anyone's being
naive any like that yeah so I think it
was online it's online it's fair game
you just go for it was like some poor
granny who's got you know a massive
Atari collection sitting there for five
dollars yeah look no no I'll give you 50
for it's worth this buck if you go to an
option you and I've got something five
bucks and I can see the excitement in
your face I guarantee they'll jack up
the price make sure you have a point if
I said yeah I was gonna say as well on
eBay in the space of time I'd be sending
a polite message to a listener someone
else will have bought it
collecting magnetic media that's you
know I have a fear of it as we all know
it degrades over time and a fear of
collecting that and for example I bought
a pack of Commodore 64 tapes that smell
a bit that's a great question my my
feeling on this is that it's good to
have the originals but I don't like to
play the originals yeah so there's a lot
of ways to play the games by SD card and
then things like that need new
technology but much prefer to have the
original and use that technology because
that's the part of those systems it's
much harder to keep in in good condition
like the hardware runs properly but the
drives and things can be a bit tricky
and they can bake into up old old media
so types of its housing tricky but I
don't the floppy floppy disks I don't
know why I did this when I was a kid but
when I used to buy singles CDs from JB I
would actually get the plastic insert
and put my floppy disc in there so they
all work perfectly fine
I don't think I'd be great as badly as
those types that watch me through those
though they can't actually they can't
fail I recently was playing one of my
favorite games on the corner city for
was Hill spot I've been to the dragon
yeah love that game played pretty cut
months ago any my mother play again a
few weeks a couple weeks ago and nothing
nothing
this is dead is completely sometimes be
the drive-in is well yeah I tried I've
put three different drivers two
different Commodores three different
Drive
not as effective with discs okay a
chance to make sure you store them in a
place where it's gonna keep him in a
reflow temperature other thing too I
found with tapes is a little bit of the
stuff that you did keep away from
moisture I found a bunch of tapes left
up in storage for years and it did get a
bit the Box a bit moist and it's just
mold is set and they're literally just
useless now apart from show pieces
that's that's it so I just so you try
and storm as best as you possibly can to
keep them like especially if this these
[ __ ] photo op that's a question he's
doing up right but if you're actually
buying types yeah there's nothing more
unfortunate when you bust that in that
box and this smells fire unfortunately
people don't least that so you're taking
any cool thank you I think we will
manage to sneak in these last two
questions so yeah sort of branching off
the it's like um so I'm be going I do
actually love the Virtual Boy and I know
that there's like rumors around some of
the arms
some of the like sort of yo unicorn
unreleased games do someone does have a
copy of them but refuses to like dump
them and release them to the community
because they want to retain that value
and yeah I guess here what your guys
thoughts are on like keeping stuff for
yourself versus sharing Eddie absolutely
sharing sorry show you drives me nuts
point people do that because you want to
preserve your stuff for people to play
in decades and turaga right so someone
actually asks a question early where
they passing their stuff on to their
kids
that's exactly why everyone's doing it
you want to preserve things so they can
actually be played on your original
hardware that was on I mean
usual preservation is great but yeah
nothing beats actually flying on a card
or whatever maybe chocolate eaten up she
comes into play and if something happens
to that in the meantime then we're gonna
lose it forever so like it's part of
history means part of the part of the
culture we all love mean we love video
games or the retro gaming so if that's
in law school history because one person
will be greedy about it and you wouldn't
imagine the original anyway
one last question will sneak in I'll try
and keep it quick yeah you've mentioned
like repairing stuff and you do most of
it yourself what if you're not this
confident do you guys have any like
places before I solve the something I
guarantee it's going straight at the
beach but there are definitely places
around still that do that I mean general
electronics is hasn't changed too much
in the last 20 30 years so anyone that's
doing that sort of work still you'll be
able to get that done any sort of you
had TV repair places and things like
that like well yeah you can do that I
mean mine I haven't got any formal
laying in it but I sort of did a lot of
scientific research and stuff so I was
sort of tinkering around with things and
yeah my way is just to keep around with
things look look online because often
problems that have relatively come and
have solutions there's got a bit of
gauge just just practicing with the
stalls are not as important so on stuff
that's not not
well yeah once once you got some
confidence then you can do that better
but there are definitely places around
because it's an important important and
there are gossip forums actually - it's
gonna say that I can actually fix things
and also um if you took on each it was a
lot of video tutorials these days as
well a lot of research reformers groups
that people had to similar issues I can
tell you almost step-by-step cards on
how to fix it but I'm self-taught as
well a lot of all sort of stuff and it's
just one of those things like I was I
might destroyed more stuff than I fixed
to begin with but yeah now it's sort of
handy to have but I learned through a
lot of guys going and asking them so how
do I do this how did that going on the
old-school forums and but before we had
like you chip was even around asking
like holidays repairman house big stuff
and digging out old manuals that from
people who head from all the tires and
things like that and workout stuff and
yeah it just says I'm saying if I just
have a gist yeah
research and practice cool look I'm
hopefully you've gotten a few useful
tips in your own so their efforts ahead
of you in collecting how can we please
give a very big thank you to the panel
Stacy Alex
you